we're going to begin this hour of course
with president biden's vow to make
russian president vladimir putin in his
words pay a price for his invasion of
ukraine mr biden told congress his
administration is committed to punishing
russian leaders for their aggression but
he vowed not to send american troops
into ukraine he also said history would
remember the war as having made russia
weaker and the rest of the world
stronger
putin's latest attack on ukraine was
premeditated
and totally unprovoked
he rejected repeated repeated efforts at
diplomacy
he thought the west and nato wouldn't
respond
he thought he could divide us at home in
this chamber in this nation
he thought he could divide us in europe
as well
but putin was wrong
well that was just one of the many
topics the president addressed last
night we're joined now by republican
senator john thune he's from south
dakota the senate minority web senator
good morning good to see you good
morning dale nice to be with you there
did seem to be a lot of bipartisan
support bipartisan applause certainly
when it came to how the president any
comments he made about ukraine and
russia do republicans for the most part
think he's doing a good job on this uh
they do i mean i think a lot of
republicans would argue that it was they
were reactive at the beginning at the
early stages maybe didn't do enough to
deter it but i i give the administration
credit i think they've done a an
exceptional job of rallying uh our
allies we're seeing a unity that we've
never seen before the president talked
about that last night and when it comes
to
you know putting these punishing
economic sanctions on russia when it
comes to supporting ukrainian people
providing military aid so they can
defend themselves we've seen um a unity
among our nato allies unlike anything
that i've seen in my lifetime and i'm
encouraged by that but that said
president
zielinski has said repeatedly we need
help we need help the vice president was
with us this morning she said no way
will there be boots on the ground we saw
interviews from ukraine a young woman
said it's hell here and when you look at
the images you must feel that too it
looks and feels very much like hell can
you imagine a scenario where we have to
say okay enough enough we have to get
involved
can you see that happening well i mean i
think if this were to spread um there's
yeah looking at the human suffering it's
heartbreaking and i think people can see
visually it's just you know it's in
front of them all the time and i think
that's rallying the american people
and the leadership of somebody like
zielinski is i think inspiring to a lot
of americans as well the question of
course obviously always is you know what
role can the united states play what
role should they play and what are our
interests there our interests are clear
when it comes to nato countries we have
an article 5 requirement obligation to
come in and support them ukraine is not
currently a nato ally
so you know those are hard questions to
answer but i think everything short of
putting boots on the ground we should be
doing and i think the administration
gets that and i think the world
community including countries that
typically aren't you know willing to
come and rally to support something like
this or coming and we're seeing even the
swiss switzerland exactly
even switzerland yeah and you know and
you have sweden and finland now want to
join nato which is something we ought to
admit them immediately but um i just
think that the the world is rallying and
interestingly enough and then this is i
think really encouraging people in
russia
are pushing back speaking out against
against putin and at some point maybe
they get to the point where
they decide they don't want him on the
scene
certainly the world is watching the
president talked about the unity agenda
last night and that's what i want to
talk to you about the unity agenda did
you hear anything in his economics plan
that you said okay i could support that
well i think there are there were
several things i thought that were unity
statements he talked about obviously
making making sure our kids are back in
school and keeping them in school that
was huge that's certainly got a lot of
plows on our side funding the police
something that was very big on our side
you know we talked at the end about
fighting opioids that is a killer in
this country we're seeing so many people
lost every year as a consequence of that
supporting our veterans there were a lot
of things in his speech i think that
were designed to sort of be a unity
agenda there are some differences
obviously and he kind of did what most
presidents do at a state of the union
speech throughout some red meat
the one issue gale that i think is going
to be really critical going forward and
it bears on the situation we're talking
about with respect to ukraine and that's
energy and gas prices which have a
choking effect on a lot of people in
this country particularly low and middle
income americans and russia's a big
producer of oil so we've got it we've
got to step up and and provide
fill that gap when it comes to liquid
fuels yeah there has to be a way to
figure out how do we hurt russia without
hurting us correct the other the other
thing i want to talk about speaking of
unity i have to talk about two of your
colleagues in the senate marjorie taylor
green and lauren bobot who chose
what is believed to be a very
inopportune time i think there's never a
good time to heckle during the state of
the union but certainly the moment that
they chose to do it i'm curious about
your reaction to their behavior last
night well i don't think there's any
place for that
you know it's a inappropriate state of
the union speech whether you agree with
the president or not it is an
opportunity to show the american people
the respect that the office deserves
well republicans come out publicly and
really say
let them know publicly that was not okay
to do well i will see
how it unfolds today you know typically
the the house um you know will if there
were steps to be taken they would the
house leadership would probably do that
but i think that there'll be plenty of
condemnation from people colleagues and
whatnot
and just a recognition that those types
of antics in a setting like that are
inappropriate and i think i think
everybody would agree with that he
mentioned his supreme court nominee
katanji brown
johnson are you planning to
can you talk about what you're planning
to do in terms of voting for her
confirmation well i think everybody at
least right now is keeping an open mind
um she comes to obviously she's very
qualified i think that we can you know
establish that right away the question
we will be looking at are or questions i
should say judicial philosophy
temperament
you know whether or not she's going to
be somebody who has a a judicial
philosophy that calls for more
intervention um more uh i would say
arguing stepping on the scales when
we're the other one but you did point
out that kachanji brown jackson i
misspoke um
is imminently qualified
so when you say keeping the options open
keeping the options open for what well i
think that you know again you in my in
my view at least the criteria i always
use is judicial philosophy matters to me
i want judges when they get on the court
to be people who are going to apply the
law on the constitution in an impartial
way
be basically somebody who calls balls
and strikes and not somebody who tries
to weigh in with a you know tries to
influence um
with some sort of political agenda uh
you know issues or cases that come
before them so those are the things i
think a lot of us will look at but i do
think that she is going to be somebody
who will get one fair treatment
respectful treatment uh she'll be
thoroughly vetted like all supreme court
justices or potential justices should be
and um so we will make sure that she
gets a fair process okay fair and
respectful yeah that's all that's a good
start yeah okay thank you senator
very good to see you thank you for
getting up early yeah